la partenza è questo se questo un
muscoloso tipo maurizio merluzzo adesso
devi andare avanti solo con solo ok
così quando hai bisogno di una mano
visto che ormai la prima parte io la sua
memoria
ti do una mano nel progetto vai avanti
ritirati evidenti lo slancio tratti lo
slancio del divino slancio e di dattilo
sangermano torniamo gioco no questo è
tutto l'organo ha tirato no sì ma che
stanno a cagare bravissimo ok ok adesso
la t shirt ma che sta succedendo
no no no ma cos'era era bellissimo ok ok
ok t bird
ma stai calmo sembra che sei sotto
effetto di adrenalina in via can charge
ammesso fare c'è uno strano che stava
cagato incredibile che lorenza voluto
fare questo gioco non si rende conto
perché fa sulle assunzioni io quando
tentò di cucinare dai regimi voglio
metterlo lassù
voglio che ste madonna non è ok beh
agganciati lì così privo di mese più
diamo la paletta al volo ne sono
concessi però non importa se lo fa
riprendere da ips allora aspetta aspetta
un attimo st aspetta un attimo fatti
fatti spiega una perché siccome non è
capito tu questo non ritenere attaccato
al corpo se non casinò devi metterlo su
così che aggancia le cose e ti ho detto
che non si fida troppo altrove
abbassarlo e là ma cosa hai preso lì
accanto ad esso aveva adesso che vi
sospetto se farò lo vede e lo spinge
verso figli verso il basso o ok però ti
spaventi tanto quando fai questa cosa
fai lo tranquillo come se stessi sapendo
ok così bar hi fi daino motta e gira ok
vabbè a destra ok lo slancio aggancia
no vedi tirati verso tirati forte forte
facebook
ok stessa cosa la stessa cosa che hai
fatto adesso perché sembra una talpa
impazzita quando sale non lo so se fai
così casi sembra così semplice mi sa che
non è possibile non può essere così può
esserlo ecco infatti scaduto hanno
lasciato qua no no no no ora ci sarà
almeno dall'inail non riesco ammette
melo manco sotto bravo bravo mi vuoi far
sognare stasera laico si è un genio
salvati calmati prende i calmanti tanto
non ti muovi se posizionati sul barile
piano piano ok adesso chi ti dai una
spinge la sua strada qui che casca bravo
calcio braccio di sgancio viagra e ricco
sia arrivato al punto impossibile su giu
bravo fermo ok ok ok ok adesso la
decadenza di un uomo in diretta torna
milito sembra troppo semplici se lo fai
vedere sembra stupido capire di utoya
non vedono tagliavano non mi basta
rileggere bravissimo non so come siamo
aspetto io la parte difficile attaccati
attaccati via attaccati vista i pezzi
staccati via stai fermo stendiamo ok
inail pugno nel culo questi attacchi il
pignone nel deretano ed attacchi ed
attacchi non cadere non cadendo ammazzo
questo noi chiediamo se il frenetico
stai fermo si sa televisione agganciare
ritirati suo ok
bastava ai fatti riportiamo da portali
sono stai fermo lì sì adesso sembra
esatto
tutti film giugno in via gaeta ganci è
così
no no dai
no no no noi salvo
no no no no io mi metto una cosa falsa
no no no no no no no no no no no è
grande
ti torna lì allora aspetta così non
voglio fare già perché se loro ti va
bene chi si professa la pizza perché qua
ci sono delle pizze monet ritorno cioè
così devi fare per arrivare là sopra ma
fatti genti
adesso qua ti metto in questa posizione
qui tu fai questo tira una botta sotto
il culo e ti attendi alla lampada che
sta lì sopra dai dai dai dai se gli
appelli alla pala j
quello che minecraft nè nè mai lo so che
se anche sei contento che ci ha fatto
giocare a scarabeo sempre giochi di
qualità anche per i pro canale
iscrivetevi non far vedere che è
semplice perché pare persone lo
installano e ci muoiono non far vedere
che è una cosa semplice
oggi alcune doti artista bene d'altra
parte vuoi andare di là voglio creare di
là poi tommy ton il nostro gioco
sì sì sì sì no stop è arrivato così un
fermo con lo fai stai fermo non lo fai
sei fermo fermo fermo allungati lucani
allungati non cadi allungati allungati
non hanno fare così puoi farlo se ti
agganci subito ok ok si riporta a fatti
domanda non voglio parlare non voglio
bene l'attacco della lanterna perché lui
pensa riesco edifici esistenti e già
difficile così tozzi cuori games sometti
il culo dove c'è il pool ha avuto le
masse nel culo linea da veri qui e ti
dai la botta sicuro no no di appoggiare
gli appoggiarti di appoggiarsi di
ratifica chi ci sta ci sta che fa in
pochissimi chilometri culo
bravo ragazzo di passare da casa ogni
sera dalle morire tutti quanti si
sistemano bravo pubblico è bravo ancora
bravo il culo oggi il culo appoggi
rifaccia tondo tondo la crisi fascia 3
travaglini fare dondola ridondanti
fiscali ok non ti levi direzionali non
ci passi da esattori te lo faccio io ti
faceva così fai il tuo video questo il
problema e ho già visto so già tutto
dopo quello hai finito dopo quale è
finito se arrivato al volto coperto che
per mattino poi scagionato di titoli e
praga come mi dondolo ordona è perfetto
così continua così il primato sito nato
continua così ea sinistra
bravo bravo e vado a fine serata fine
alla fine devi dotati mezzo paternò
storica dei viali fa casino cosa che gli
è rimasta è derivato è rifinito io ti
caccio di casa anche da fuoco lasciando
mai portato il mare in questa casa
avanti sono io tecnica ci sono care e
borsisti casse di stallo tutto da solo
subito subito riportami su tela tra
lecce e facile da qua vuoi che vada
avanti della mia gancia quando dai ok ma
viviano quagliano ti spingi spingi no il
[Musica]
t spi che mamma avanti avanti almeno
perfetto ma va bene sprechi per me va
bene per me va bene invece dovresti
saltare
il software
lo so che sta succedendo devo arrivare
in alto cioè siamo arrivati in alto il
nostro nei come cava ma scusate ma
[Musica]